hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
but Monday January 4th 2016 a brand new
year brand new year brand-new you are
you going to make the changes that
you've always wanted to make where you
going to stop telling yourself you're
going to change it actually God Baron
change I always love the pressure the
beginning of the new year to be like I
know is that one great thing right like
with you like I shaking off the last
year you know like I don't know who the
[ __ ] that guy was right like lying to
yourself like you're not the same person
[ __ ] one minute later when it becomes
a new year or you do the real childish
thing is you blame everybody else for
your own [ __ ] problems you know can't
wait for this year to be over man she
spent so much [ __ ] [ __ ] this year
just like the worst [ __ ] year I can't
wait for the next book a year it's like
you the law you're going to change
anything you're going to break up with
the person you're going to stop getting
drunk of being a dick and picking fights
in a bar right huh all of that [ __ ]
are you just going to think that
magically because there's a six there
now instead of a five that all of a
sudden the world is going to change you
don't have to adjust Oh am i
reprimanding somebody right now I think
I am I don't know why I have no idea why
I'm recording this at about 8:30 in the
morning
lost honglei's time my wife's still
sleeping downstairs so I get it I got to
try to stay at medium energy medium
energy here for the rest of this [ __ ]
podcast or whatever I'm kinda gotta be
honest with you I went to bed last night
I was sad I love the holidays and I'm
sad that they're [ __ ] over
I had another great you know holiday
break and to think that it's all going
to [ __ ] start over again
you know here we go another [ __ ] year
doing the road right and [ __ ] and doing
all this stuff here we [ __ ] go again
had the whole thing just got just
totally overwhelming with me
and I was just [ __ ] laying in bed you
know you know when you do [ __ ] look
too far ahead into your [ __ ] life you
know it just gets too [ __ ]
overwhelming and then maybe you start
here in the safe but you don't tell me I
was here my head I was here that's wrong
make the world go away something jumped
in and get it off my shoulders that's
what I feel like the most pathetic
emotion you could have make the world go
away can you just get a go in there and
just pout you know I got asked a
question about depression is it actually
a chemical thing or is that just an
adult world word for like somebody's
just got sort of piling you know I think
a lot of times when people go I'm
depressed it's just you just kind of
feeling sorry for yourself and you know
the ones that say it's like a chemical
imbalance you just like you just shift
your head really quickly the chemicals
go back to the other way and you'll
cheer up you know don't believe the
mainstream media you know in all the
pharmaceutical companies with their
drugs man is there anything funnier than
when somebody who's not a [ __ ] doctor
you know just starts going on and on a
bug let me tell you something man I'm
telling you all you got to do is just go
up walk up to an oak tree can't be a
birch can't be a maple go up to an oak
tree and just bite on a little sapling
you just not a guy's got a little piece
of bark and you stick it between you
just like chew you just stick to you're
going all of that and you depression
will go away yeah it is true it is true
the Native Americans used to do it they
were never depressed that's what they
used to do until the white man came it
took their bark away now look at him so
I'm grumpy just like the white man say
they couldn't get any more saplings with
the tree bark there anyways uh Mersey
and his wife left yesterday so the house
is empty again it just stinks man I was
having a great
[ __ ] time enjoying it now sky all
[ __ ] starts over again
Marie starting the year off my office is
a [ __ ] mess you know I'm the worst I
can't find the sticker to put on my
[ __ ] license plate I know I got it I
don't know where the [ __ ] it is it just
it all starts over there just fun times
over
fun time is over you know what we still
got the Christmas tree up because Mia
liked it extra a lot this year so I
still after that I still have to go
through that sad [ __ ] operation
bringing that goddamn thing outside and
I told you I disposed that thing like a
[ __ ] mob hit you're never going to
find the body
but [ __ ] neighbor already through his
right out on the street just tosses it
out there right
some dead hooker you know what I mean
cut the [ __ ] thing up and you put it
in the barrel that's what you do I get
my might the green barrel right we got
the green barrels out here and that's
just like grass clippings and all that
[ __ ] I have a whole [ __ ] Christmas
tree and then the lid closes completely
you'd have no [ __ ] idea come on
people how difficult is if you cut all
the branches off then you just left with
the trunk and then you just section it
up that's it drop the ripping right the
[ __ ] in there it's not a problem you
wear your safety goggles you know so
nobody can see you cry and as you're
doing it I don't understand what the
[ __ ] problem is but god damn it get
out there or dispose of the [ __ ] tree
correctly environmentally would it be
more correct if you just sort of spread
it across your lawn the tree is just
going to end up in a landfill or even
worse out in the ocean they don't the
log is the ocean I can't wait to get to
this [ __ ] thing later on in this
podcast where this guy is trying to
claim that the the earth can sustain 100
billion people
I really cannot get I cannot wait I just
glanced at it and looked at it how the
[ __ ] you arrived at that number and I
actually tried to find shy started
looking up how many [ __ ] people the
earth can sustain and what I've
immediately found was that nobody could
say for certain but the numbers
estimated we're nowhere near
a hundred million [ __ ] people out of
billions sorry so I cannot wait to read
this guy somehow claiming that is enough
farmland to feed a hundred [ __ ]
billion people I don't know okay do we
stack each other on top of one another
and even then the elephants get to roam
free anymore except where all the
[ __ ] animals if it was on a billion
people on the planet I would think that
cannibalism would slowly start to become
legal they would have they'd have farm
people or stock people that's what they
call them and they would be simply be
used for food you know we just you know
and of course it would be you know the
evil white man would decide who it is
that gets eaten first
you know maybe they'd start with like
the pygmies or something like that
because it'd be like I well you know
there they are a particular race but
they're not as tall as most people in
that race so you know this sort of bike
size they're like sliders right sliders
they're like human sliders you know get
a little honeyBun you know stick a
[ __ ] ankle between the two all right
why would you do an ankle ankle me so
anyways I still feel [ __ ] up from the
Rose Bowl man I still you know I barely
got any sleep of Paul being out here and
then we also performed New Year's Eve
down the orpheum and I bought this suit
to wear New Year's Eve I found it like
over the summertime it was just all
white suit jacket and pants but you know
from from a distance it reads all white
but when you come up to it it had these
tiny black polka dots you know what I
mean tiny and I walked into the store
and I was on like the [ __ ] 70% off
rack because it's really one of those
things like where the [ __ ] are you ever
going to wear that and I was like that's
a perfect shoe for [ __ ] New Year's
you put the black [ __ ] solid black
shirt underneath they have a little
black pocket square right and you walk
out there like John Travolta
but a pitbull Papa did it did a well you
can't tell by the way I tell my jokes
I'm a [ __ ] hack
no time for originality I'm sorry
[ __ ] [ __ ] jokes exposing the jokes I
don't like to use concepts Oh No
anyways so that was once again me
standing to the side of the stage going
like I am either good people either
going to like this suit or I'm going to
get heckled the entire time the mouth
here but either way either way it's
going to add to the [ __ ] show but uh
as I predicted it was New Year's I
addressed the suit I said this is the
only night I could wear it people left
and was a it was a great [ __ ] time
great old theatre and I had a bunch of
people come out a bunch of friends you
know people hadn't seen in a couple
years people don't you know kind of in
my life it was awesome and I love doing
New Year's out here in LA because I
don't have to travel or anything like
that and I get to do the job I love to
do however I think that's the last New
Year's Eve I'll do I think I'll do like
the 30th next time because I got to tell
you the second show ends right by the
way I had to do the countdown like two
jokes before my closing joke I was like
halfway through this one bit that I've
been trying to work on I kept [ __ ] up
the ending I was going to try a new
ending to it because the ending was too
sad for every [ __ ] city in this
nation other than Dallas Texas Dallas
Texas truck and enjoyed the [ __ ] out of
the original ending and I'm right in the
middle of that bit and I see that it's
11:59 so then I had to get out of a bit
take a pause and then do the countdown
and then the streamers came out right
lovey Nia came out on stage gave me a
kiss so the guys came you know
we [ __ ] waves and everything and then
everybody gets off the stage and then I
had to go back into my act which was it
just ended up being funny because it was
really weird so anyways we end up doing
the show and then as we leave was stuck
in this brutal traffic I'm like what the
[ __ ] there must have been something
going on because you're in downtown LA
too much much something going
on down it like LA live or some [ __ ]
down there that's right near the Staples
Center and then I [ __ ] realize the
next day it was Motley Crue's final show
ever at the Staples Center and I was
like ah [ __ ] that's the traffic we got
stuck in and there's actually a clip up
on YouTube of you know Tommy Lee the
drummer does it has the whole [ __ ]
rollercoaster attached to his drum kit
where it turns upside down and it goes
out over the crowd and then comes back
and all that [ __ ] I mean the right there
alone you know if you're the other
members in the band you got to be like
dude this better be [ __ ] worth it
because the amount of money that's
coming on our check to [ __ ] carry
that rig out on the [ __ ] road you
know what I mean that's one of those
overhead costs so I don't know if you
guys have seen the video there last
[ __ ] show ever and the thing gets
stuck it gets stuck and Tommy he's
upside down on this thing in this roadie
scampering up the side of it like the
[ __ ] Apes and Planet of the Apes when
they were on the Golden Gate Bridge
right scampering up the side of this
thing and Tommy's just upside down like
what the [ __ ] man the [ __ ] thing's
busted he's like hey LA he's like what
you look you look interesting when I'm
hanging upside down in Los Angeles he's
just hanging upside down it's the most
excruciating ly uncomfortable thing I've
seen a performer have to go through in a
long time he did what the [ __ ] he could
do I mean once you just go well [ __ ] the
rollercoaster man and you're still
hanging upside down I mean what do you
do it's just [ __ ] brutal and the fact
that it happened on the very last show
you know I don't want to start any
infighting I know the band doesn't exist
anymore but I think Vince Neil did it I
think the lead singer probably all these
years you know he's used to being out
front and all the chicks digging them
you know walking around with his Barbie
hair and all that
and then all the drama goes all the way
out over the crowd and everybody's
looking at Emmy maybe you got sick of it
after all these years the amount of
money that was coming out of his
paycheck to bring that [ __ ] looky
loop roller coaster with the [ __ ]
drum kit in it and he probably went
probably everybody look at that over
there and they just pulled the fuse that
doesn't make any sense building he's
sabotaging his own show well you know I
can have a [ __ ] theory somebody could
just email me with no [ __ ] links or
anything whatsoever and just tell me
that this earth can sustain 100 billion
people anyways so we were stuck in that
traffic I didn't get home until like
1:30 1:45 fell asleep around 2 and then
I had to be up at 10 of 10 after 5:00 to
then be outside for the next 13 hours at
the at the Rose Bowl this year we
brought 8 people and one of my buddies
who went there he just called it the
goon parade and I got to be honest with
you uh that's kind of what we were I
don't remember so much of it I remember
the whole game because I just stopped
drinking because I had to drive so I
just remember walking to the stadium and
after that I remember the entire [ __ ]
game so I'll take you through what I
remember so we [ __ ] get there right
first time ever we get there so [ __ ]
early
they haven't even opened the gates yet
so when we finally get in we're parked
just outside the VIP parking I mean we
had like a five minute walk to the
stadium was [ __ ] tremendous and I
remember
Bartnik giving me a Miller High Life the
big grin on his face because we always
have the Miller High Life to start the
day long I had got his [ __ ] Y I had
made it by the way he made it you know
I'll never smile again he made it and he
got all three of his fires going and
getting ready for the breakfast
sandwiches and I want to say that I
waited till after I had law had
unbelievable breakfast and
it's the best breakfast sandwich I have
every [ __ ] year is that one and it
was absolutely delicious and my favorite
thing was looking over at versi after he
was two bites in I was like hey Paul I
go how's that breakfast sandwich and he
just [ __ ] shot me it looked like a
you [ __ ] kidding me so I was already
psyched I knew he was going to have a
great time and after that I was like hey
I'm like who want to eat her everybody's
like yeah right so he poured like
[ __ ] eight of them and I had these
--piece those big square ice cubes I had
made those who brought him over in a
ziplock bag like a [ __ ] you know kilo
of coke so I dropped them into
everybody's plastic cup and that's so
big they don't make it all the way down
to the bottom of the glass so the booze
is actually below the ice level and
everybody's laughing I'm like well you
just got a [ __ ] you got to pour more
booze in there and then you put your
hand over the ice cube but it'll melt
down and that became the technique and
then after that it just became like a
slideshow just the stuff I remember I
remember
Bartnik does this thing every year he
gets off the you know gets out of the
truck and he just screams at the top of
his lungs ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the granddaddy of all and everybody's
always terrified sort of laughing
whatever
so these Iowa fans somebody just said ah
we do not need that voice here and
immediately we're not liking us and I
don't know I think that for whatever
reason they were really they were like I
want to say older than me but I'm pretty
[ __ ] old at this point I'm 47
I think they were in their 50s and for
whatever reason they were playing Drake
alright and it was like [ __ ] 7:00 in
the morning and their [ __ ] music was
louder than our music so we're sitting
there the Sun hasn't even come up yet
and we're listening to you used to call
me on your cell phone you'll use do you
you too and it just was [ __ ] with
them and I go god I'm angry playing that
[ __ ] song like that song is like
that's like there's a few songs that get
played so much that you never need to
hear them again I think
the original song was in the mood
biting Benny Goodman was a Glenn Miller
got it at a bird a rabbit or two but at
that that happened I never need to hear
that song ever again right I'd say
bookending from way back in the day too
[ __ ] right now it goes in the mood
Glenn Miller and then cellphone by Drake
I don't win an Emmy I can only mean one
thing
oh he's such a [ __ ] in that [ __ ]
song
it's basically a I used to just [ __ ] you
I used to I use you and then he she
moves away and then he's upset that the
woman got on with the life you know what
a [ __ ] he's is he one of those
possessive guys who once he [ __ ] up and
he feels like he owns it for the rest of
his life let it go dude all you were
doing was [ __ ] her now what now you
want her because she's not there anymore
to come over and lick your balls and
shape up your beard afterwards I mean
[ __ ] move on with your life Drake
yo yo yo yo yo yo so that's [ __ ]
going on and all I know and they were
annoyed without loud
Bartnik yelled so I don't know what
happened somewhere between the beer the
shot in the breakfast sandwich I glanced
over and the older guy is chirping and
[ __ ] bark Nick's here and bartnick is
just staring straight ahead 600 yards
stare just standing there and I see the
guy talking talking talking and then I
just see Joe just shrug his shoulders be
like well you know I don't like your
music and I got to be honest with you
[ __ ] I don't know what else he said
but ten minutes later those people were
just gone and we never saw him again I
don't know if they had like some VIP
[ __ ] you know Iowa Hawkeye [ __ ]
barbecue thing the tent that they were
going to I have no idea but we would die
and laughing
one conversation would joke like the hey
Q mind keeping it down a little bit and
Joe just gave him the death [ __ ] you
know the six hundred yard stare and that
was it they just [ __ ] left so that
problem was solved then we were throwing
the football around and remembered
everything but forgot the bacon and
what's-his-face long I was be able to
call an audible and he had some bison
meat or something like that and bacon
grease figure that one out I don't know
how the [ __ ] he did it but yeah and
everything was going great now we're
throwing the football around and then at
some point I was just so [ __ ]
hammered that I fell down and I was one
of those drunk Falls where it took me
like 17 I started falling and it took
like seventeen seconds for me to fall
and the entire time I was saying I'm
sorry it's now known yet now known as
the I'm sorry fall and it took me so
long to fall that just about everybody
at the tailgate thought and I think with
what I happened was I was standing well
I had had this tent you know when I was
four posted ten things I was standing
underneath it and unbeknownst to me was
right behind me was my cooler and all
the other coolers and all the bags of
groceries sort of sprinkled out right
and I was talking and I did an
about-face to start walking and
immediately tripped over the first
cooler alright and as I was trying to
get my leg to an open area without
stepping on hamburger buns I just you
know there wasn't any space to put my
feet down and I was doing like it was
almost like a wide receiver after they
catch a football and they try to stay
inbounds advance down the sidelines I
was doing that but in between condiments
and food and [ __ ] like that and I just I
never regained my balance but I didn't
go down so like so what I got it was
probably real time was probably like a
four second fall but that's a long time
you know if you just fall Bab you're on
the ground you know in under a second I
would think depending
you're really short and you get there a
little quicker so I just kept on sorry
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry it right is
like my buddy Nate came over to try and
stop me from falling I just [ __ ] him
landed on my back and I twisted my left
knee and I hear the whole place laughing
and I was laughing evidently my last
step I stepped in some avocado and
slipped on that and I just [ __ ] went
down like just thud right on my back I
landed like a wrestler so it didn't even
hurt was just my entire backside hit the
ground at the same time and I remember
talking about it later and I was like
yeah I didn't spill my drink I didn't
spill my drinking every check yeah you
did you did you spill tit all over the
front of your jacket so then I
remembered getting up the apple pies out
I remember the brisket and the ribs
being done and those were delicious oh I
had killing it as always and then I
think I smoked a cigar next yeah I
smoked a cigar and then we had the apple
pies and everybody freaked out they
loved them and then I was yeah then I
smoked a cigar I was like all right I
got a [ __ ] sober up here because in
six hours the game will be over and
we'll be done and then I got a drive so
[ __ ] hang on a second hang on
all right I'm back sorry about that head
woman [ __ ] knows so anyways so let me
get into the we get into the game and I
still don't know his [ __ ] name
because I was hammered the running back
for Stanford just was why did you go to
the stadium he already ran for a
touchdown and then it was just like it
was like a [ __ ] Hollywood movie they
couldn't stop this kid the kid even had
another one he ran like 70 yards for a
touchdown they had to bring it back they
just couldn't [ __ ] get the kid down
and before you knew it it was like 28 to
nothing 28 2010 it was 35 to nothing and
we still had like half half of the
second quarter that the [ __ ] gate was
just over it was the worst Rose Bowl
game as far as being competitive that
I've been to slash the
greatest individual performance I've
ever seen we got to see that kitty set
the record for the most all-purpose
yards ever in a Rose Bowl and this is
the granddaddy of them all the original
Rose orginal I guess Bowl game even
though the Yale Bowl is the original
Bowl stadium forget that one anyways so
we got to see that and fortunately
during halftime I didn't have to watch
the Stanford band which by the way is
just limey could you could they be more
of a bunch of hipsters though the whole
thing is like they're mocking the
halftime show yet not showing how you
can improve it so there's like no risk
you just sort of mocking the whole
[ __ ] thing like which is to me
classic hipster behavior to me that's
the difference between nerds and
hipsters you know what I mean it's like
all right so you think what the the
standard way that a halftime show is
done is too rigid so you guys I just
hate how the whole thing's now oh these
guys are crazy
oh look at the guy with the [ __ ]
rainbow wig playing the drum oh what's
he going to do I don't think it's
[ __ ] dumb and then I just thought it
was a badly made California look bad
when they made fun of the Iowa people
with the whole uh you know farmers only
and once again I don't know I don't know
anybody in the Stanford band but just
seems like that classic I live near an
ocean therefore I'm smarter than you but
something about people live on the coast
with their whole attitude towards the
middle of the countries the funniest
[ __ ] thing ever to me like flyover
state and blah blah blah blah blah and
all that it's like those [ __ ] people
that you're sitting in making fun of you
know I think farmers old here you would
go out there and go [ __ ] your sister
it's like you mean the people who grow
the food supply for this country you
[ __ ] dope what are you doing that
with your flute oh look at the cool kid
with the clarinet I don't know I thought
it was a hacky joke and I don't know you
know what I mean look if you guys work
you know just decided to trash one
another then it would be funny but it
just kind of comes off like it's like
when Ricky Gervais
does that [ __ ] at the Golden Globes you
know what I mean he hires the staff of
writers to write roast jokes aimed at
people who showed up with acceptance
speeches and it's just algae did you win
that one what are you gonna do next
slap an ice cream out of a five-year-old
hand I just I don't know it's the same
thing with that I thought it was douchey
behavior but fortunately I missed all of
it you know and uhm how we did paper
mache cow it'll be epic uh kill yourself
it'd be one thing if Stanford ever
actually put on a good halftime show
like wow this band is next-level
I get why they're trying to break the
whole [ __ ] format of it but if you
actually watch the competition to the
best [ __ ] college bands out there
they're [ __ ] drum lines alone would
destroy anyone in that band so you know
I don't know every once in a while I'm a
[ __ ] conservative and I'm a
conservative on that one why just AG you
kind of [ __ ] made an ass of yourself
but anyways I just hate the deliberately
bad dancing that they do I think if
you're going to mock dancing you should
be able to dance well you know to just
suck at it and then be like making fun
of it then you just [ __ ] like I yeah
yeah just like we thought yeah you don't
have any Talent [ __ ] the Stanford band I
love their football program though
anyways uh so while all of that was
going on all that that [ __ ]
nauseating hipster behavior the looks on
their faces like everyone in the crowd
is like their mind is blown like oh my
god what's going on it's the [ __ ] up if
you're in the band
you playing the [ __ ] triangle out
there you're not a rebel you're not
freaking anybody out so anyways we
actually went out to the concession
stand and you know just standing the
whole [ __ ] halftime were standing in
this in this line and we actually missed
the first three minute to the the third
quarter understanding in the slams
comedian Sean Quinn from
clearly he's [ __ ] hilarious right so
we get all the way up there and I
ordered a pretzel in the water and he
ordered a pretzel and something else and
I'm [ __ ] coming around he's still
drinking you know he doesn't have to
drive so he still [ __ ] drinking
during the game and they hand him the
pretzel and he proceeded after we waited
a half an hour for our food she hands
him the pretzel he [ __ ] just fumbled
it it was like a bad exchange between
the quarterback and the running back you
know they like bump into each other the
dude never quite has the ball he never
quite had the pretzel and it just goes
end over end and like slow motion and
falls salt side down onto the concrete
where everybody's standing he
immediately bends down and picks it up
and I'm looking at him and he just goes
he's like it's all right it's all right
my kid you got to give that thing back
things like not sorryi right he doesn't
give a [ __ ] so I'm dying laughs like
guy's a maniac it's like people walking
in and out of restrooms and then coming
over here standing in his food money out
of your [ __ ] mind but still kind of
drunk so then I go over we're putting
mustard on the pretzel and then I don't
know where [ __ ] lion shows up and he
had he has done for the piece of his
breast cloning game until I almost
[ __ ] fainted I was laughing so hard
[ __ ] thing was on the ground it's
like it was like watching a poison them
I couldn't say anything I was clapping
so [ __ ] hard so then we get we
finally get back into the finally get
back into the stadium and then just the
whole game just stopped I mean it was
barely any scoring Iowa came back and
scored a couple I was psyched for versi
because he he went to Bethany but he bet
Stanford and then in the next half he
bet the over he won both of them so he
picked up a buck fifty something like
that and I don't know he just ended up
going back the game was over and then we
went back to the truck
we were hanging out we got the bonfire
going the Sun was down and in the middle
of having a bonfire all of a sudden this
kid comes walking by with another friend
this Iowa kid and he just goes he just
goes hey he goes like that bonfire was
illegal you can't have it it's illegal
and right he was probably like go like
ha ha ha I'm just [ __ ] around the
Philly guy he goes shut the [ __ ] up you
[ __ ] blah blah blah
right and then the kid [ __ ] pops up
his chest it's like kind of us sitting
here this kid was like he was like 5 6 5
7 becomes running up you know talking
all this [ __ ] and I'm just sitting there
looking at him like it's [ __ ] 10 of
us here you know
do you have an Uzi like what what are
you doing right so it gets into it is
back and forth the next thing you know
birdies over there and it looks like
firs he's about ready to square off with
the guy cuz the guy kept walking away
but I got alright whatever whatever and
he'd be like oh so it's fine we'll [ __ ]
you because we know he's had the last
thing and then we'd be like [ __ ] you and
it just kept going back and forth back
and forth and finally the guy's like 30
yards away birdies talking to him and I
thought like oh this kids going to suck
a room so I got up over there go relax
relax relax and then all of a sudden I
hear a bottle break in this [ __ ]
maniac silly guy right [ __ ] place
bottle it's the plenty of thing ever
it breaks the bottle on the pavement any
[ __ ] he did it way too hard when he
brought his hand up there was no bottle
left he just shattered the [ __ ] thing
but then he like mimes like he still had
the bottle in his hand and this is the
best part the Iowa kid talking [ __ ]
never flinched so now he's pretending he
had a bottle in his hand I don't know
what he was going to do was like a
[ __ ] movie just like what the [ __ ]
right so the dude finally goes away has
to yell a few more [ __ ] things and it
was still ridiculous then we went back
and we was sitting around and all we did
for the rest of the time
there was make fun of Sean and how there
was no bottle left he actually cut his
hand and we were all just didn't go and
like - what were you going to do what
he's like I don't know I don't know what
I always wanted to do that it was just
[ __ ] ridiculous though and by then
you know actually as I was coming out of
the game I was I was so sober I had
already gotten into the [ __ ] hangover
so I just started drinking waters and
[Music]
then had another two hot dogs and a
hamburger and I got to tell you dude my
body was like what the [ __ ] and I just
drove home like with a splitting [ __ ]
headache stone silver splitting [ __ ]
headache and and then by then my knee
was killing me and I was walking like I
just written the horse from here to
[ __ ] Massachusetts and I was I was
shot I came home and I just [ __ ] just
pounded like three water's
and that was it was during that time
where I was just thinking to myself like
I'm never going to that game again like
[ __ ] you know when you out three to
six weeks with a [ __ ] knee string
cause you went to a tailgate you really
got to start like looking back on like
what the [ __ ] but it happened to me
again this year you know every year I go
you know I'm going to go a little easy
going to go easy I want to remember as
much of this tailgate as I can like I
passed out like an hour of it and part
of it was the alcohol but the other part
was just like I'd only gotten three
hours sleep you know there's only so far
you can go when you start the day off
with a melih all right let me but it was
one of one of the best uh one of the
best [ __ ] tailgates and I loved
hanging with [ __ ] all the new people
that came along and I'm now of course
obsessed with the Philly accent is the
funniest [ __ ] accent got a big big
easel everything good John all right
hang on a second all right
let me type in my password here so I can
do a couple of readings
come on I love that they make you pick
such a [ __ ] difficult one that you
know it takes me like three times the
type mining because there's some
capitals and then there's some not
capitals like if someone broken my
computer I understand what they were
beginning all right okay oh Jesus I mean
those I have the [ __ ] energy it
usually takes me three days to get over
the [ __ ] Rose Bowl this is the third
day all right
oh I love we start up Otto pulled me on
DS me on DS no more sweaty balls but who
do do me undies beyond de get them all
for the fall take some leaves in your
tank say your balls are sweaty no they
ain't cuz you got nice and soft [ __ ]
balls even in 2016 oh yeah even getting
for your check right viennese what's the
secret to new year's resolutions make
the first step really easy like the
first thing you do every day put on
underwear this year I would be old in
with the new step into a fresh new pair
of me undies the world's most
comfortable underwear and it's the
easiest resolution you'll make head to
me undies comm choose from a variety of
styles and limited-edition patterns for
both men and women and they'll be
delivered right to your door you know
it's [ __ ] hilarious about this is I
never throw out my underwear I don't
throw my underwear until his actual
holes in them and it takes a long
[ __ ] time you know I have underwear
that still from when I was in my 30s I
know I do the undies is the next level
of underwear every pair don't be like me
get new underwear every pair is made
from their signature motel logo modal
model fabric proven to be twice the
softest cotton they don't feel better
than they don't just feel better than
regular on these they make you feel
invincible I'll kick your ass buddy Mike
balls are dry and it's guaranteed to be
the most comfortable underwear you've
ever worn on your first pair is free so
don't start your new year and old
underwear make a change and head to me
undies comm / / right now get 20% off
your first order
shipping is always free for all orders
in the US and Canada so for 20% off your
first order of the world's most
comfortable underwear head to me undies
comm / / right now
alright Dollar Shave Club everybody you
know I got to be honest as much as it
sucks that I lost all this advertising I
do like having to read less so it kind
of works out all right Dollar Shave Club
all right you guys I figured it out I've
discovered the key to an amazing shape
it's simple that's exactly what
dollarshaveclub.com does and why I'm a
proud member like millions of others
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
raises right to my door for a third of
the price of what the greedy raising
razor corporations charge you need have
to go down to the store to get them both
my wallet and face finally get some
early early start joining
dollarshaveclub.com means you can afford
to shave with a fresh blade anytime you
want which feels fantastic and for the
smoothest shave ever use fresh Dollar
Shave Club blades with their dr. cavite
v-shape it's not your average shave
cream it's high-quality ingredients that
make your skin feel soft smooth and
moisturize your blade will just glide
across your skin if you want the most
amazing shave possible take it from me
use a fresh DSC blade Dollar Shave Club
and dr. copies ez shea butter two
reasons to join dr. dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / / and
the guys who have stuck with me through
thick and thin stands calm everyone you
know one great resolution you can make
for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business I know an easy
way to start that anyways with
stamps.com
think about how much time you've wasted
go into the post office driving there
finding parking standing behind the old
lady you know priority or Express which
one of these is overnight try to figure
that [ __ ] out stamps.com is a better way
to get postage
use what you already have your computer
your printer to get official US postage
for any letter or package then the
mailman comes and picks it up with every
stamp with stamps.com everything you do
at the post office you can do right from
your desk at a fraction of the cost of
one of those expensive postage meter I
use Ryu's flash recommend-- babcom it's
so convenient any time I'm setting on my
posters or anything I'm going to sell up
to my shows I use Famicom I'm a [ __ ] if
I can figure it out so can you right now
sign up for sam's calm and use my last
name bar for this special offer for week
trial plus $110 bonus offer that
includes postage and a digital scale
don't wait go to Stan's calm before you
do anything else you click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
typing BER that Stan's calm enter BER
alright and that's it mercifully that's
the last bit of reading I have to do
here for the [ __ ] week alright and
with that let's get to can we talk a
little NFL football for us you look at
that dad boo - boo dude I would say the
Patriots in Seattle entered the playoffs
the exact opposite way I'm going to go
out on a limb the Patriots just could
not get anything going offensively our
offensive line is just it's it's [ __ ]
she had it dude we got nobody left
every time Brady with the past there was
someone in the backfield not defense big
great army was holding them for like 10
points for most of the [ __ ] game but
hopefully we can get healthy or I don't
I don't see it's going too deep into the
playoffs this year Seattle on the other
10 I'll tell you right now this is the
wild-card King nobody wants to play but
you go there she sells fugly peaking too
early
Seattle look like world beaters and the
way that they handled the [ __ ]
Cardinals yesterday they made them I
mean I don't the Cardinals started to
come back or not I mean I watched the
first [ __ ] half and it looked like an
NFL team plaintiff CFL team let me check
out the final score here I mean I think
it shipped another phenomenal coaching
job by Pete Carroll and he's got it he's
like he's got him right well 36
two-six yeah they just destroyed them
scoring it will do whenever the whatever
the [ __ ] they wanted you know Arizona
special teams was looking like [ __ ] that
field goal kicker make a couple extra
points I don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on with them and they couldn't
tackle anybody on punch or kickoffs
the only question mark I saw with
Seattle was their kicker missed another
one and Richard Sherman's hair that's
the only thing I found that's the second
time this year Sherman has been brought
down by his hair to the point they
actually thought it was a facemask he
went down so [ __ ] his head went down
but other than that I was I was the guy
you know a couple weeks ago thinking
like you know Arizona and Carolina now I
think it's uh Carolina it would place
the adalat home but I got to tell you
she al doesn't give a [ __ ]
they've been there the last two years in
a row if they wouldn't again this year a
lot of people going to be like oh
they're evil one play away for winning
it three times in a row that's absolute
[ __ ] that's absolute [ __ ]
you went two in a row if you win the
[ __ ] thing it changes it changes your
vibe you know defending versus bad taste
in your mouth you know what I mean the
hour long do you think Pete Carroll was
able to actually get eight hours sleep
after that Super Bowl like the drive
that he's had to get back because that
they [ __ ] that thing up flash Malcolm
Butler made one of the greatest
defensive plays of all time like battle
you know there's a reason why nobody's
ever won three in a row
it's you know it's hard to stay that
[ __ ] motivated I think anyways and I
know watching the Patriots when the
defending Super Bowl champions versus
just being the Patriots which is bad
enough people want to beat you bad
enough but when you're the defending
Super Bowl champion even the [ __ ] teams
try hard against you
but anyway having said all that you know
the way she has played over the last
month in that last game like they look
like [ __ ]
old beaters so and us I don't know if we
could beat the Broncos at this point
without [ __ ] injured we are even went
there a new quarterback I that was hard
to see Peyton Manning be a backup man
but he took it like a gentleman I wonder
if that was his last game I wonder I
wonder I wonder if all right let's get
to let's get to the [ __ ] questions
here for this week right and by the way
for all the Canadiens fans I'm not
ducking the fact that you guys destroyed
us in that game I just haven't seen it
yet I started to watch it yesterday and
after all the [ __ ] the hoopla and all of
that [ __ ] I got like a minute and a half
in the game and they already scored
that's just like oh man I think the
final was five to one so congratulations
to you [ __ ]
but um no I got to fix my cooler to my
cooler took a beating both hinges were
broken as the interior strap thanks
thankfully igloo makes a repair kit
night you know it's obviously an easy
repair I got to get that [ __ ] taken
care of this week that [ __ ] coolers
been to every Rose Bowl I got to fix it
up here
who knows maybe when I fell on the one
I'm not the [ __ ] lid off a thing all
right breakfast here we go there's no
way it did 45 minutes Jesus Christ it's
flying by all right breakfast bill I'm a
father of two young children and I hold
a nine-to-five corporate job don't feel
bad for me though I love my job that's
awesome
I want you to love your job and he goes
and I don't [ __ ] about how hard it is
to be a parent he goes I maintain a
decent diet I was a college athlete so I
have a basic understanding of the human
body
granted you and I spend our mornings
differently I freeze my ass off every
morning for five to six months of the
year I was wondering what you do for
breakfast every morning I don't know
what do you mean you freeze your ass off
what do you do you guys I'm wondering
what you do for breakfast every morning
and then he goes on to say I'm always on
the go and I'm not hungry right when I
leave for work which leaves me in the
car and at the office for the rest of
the morning not a lot of options beyond
a banana and a coffee
it's too cold to smoothies what's the
man to do what's your morning food
routine
well when I'm being smart I have two
eggs over-easy and I have some oatmeal
with a banana and maybe some blueberries
I don't have any bread or any of that
stuff and then between breakfast and
lunch I have an apple and at the lunch I
have turkey slices with a side salad and
then at four o'clock I have a meat with
the protein insect o'clock meat with the
protein and meat with the protein I have
a protein with vegetables - my brain is
shot in I have yeah I have a protein
with some vegetables eggs meat with the
protein and then I have bread with some
carbs that's what I end up doing and
then I just I stop eating around six
five six is when I have my last meal and
then I just drink waters after that if I
get really hungry I just have celery
with peanut butter and I got to get back
to that diet because I've been cooking
up a [ __ ] storm bacon and all that
type of stuff and I have three goals
this month I'm going to make a quiche
I'm going to make a [ __ ] lasagna and
I'm gonna make the conscious chicken the
last two or mario batali recipes and
Dondre chicken isn't that bad the
[ __ ] the lasagna is pretty bad but
there's eel in it and I just can't I
can't get myself to eat lobster or veal
I just just what the [ __ ] they go
through I mean I know the chickens and
cows already have a bad enough thing but
like it just seems extra [ __ ] cruel
boiling something alive and having
something just fit a [ __ ] cage
forever so it's softer and tastes better
when you eat if it's [ __ ] brutal
anyways alright so what's my morning
routine yo if I was you and I had a guy
would eat I would get up I would make
the time and I would at least just have
some oatmeal I mean I thought I don't
have kids I mean I just hear you guys
talking about having kids makes me glad
I don't have any I mean just things go
[ __ ]
[Music]
just never-ending never-ending I don't
know so I will or what do you do for
breakfast alright I told you I did the
whole day yeah if I was I would have to
make the time I would definitely say
that you got to make the time and I
think the best thing for working out as
you do it in the morning and you just
get it out of the way and then you have
a healthy breakfast and that gets you on
the right track to start the day to
start off the day if you're eating bad
and then try to be like well don't worry
I'm going to go to the gym later
the problem is with bad food is it
chemically [ __ ] your body and it makes
you just want to lay down and do nothing
so if you start the day I don't know
just do that death the 10th number I was
telling you guys about the 10th start
off is like 10 jumping jacks 10 burpees
10 push-ups 10 alternating lunges 10
situps
forget the [ __ ] order I haven't done
it but you can so you can look it up on
the internet and find it and then you go
from 10 and then you do 9 jumping jacks
9 per piece 9 push-ups 9 situps 9
alternate leg jumps 9 squat jumps and
then you do 8 you go all the way down to
1 and then you know you pretty much
winded and then if you want to add a
little more cardio to it you skip skip
rope for a round or two or three or
whatever you want to [ __ ] do you can
do that workout like a hotel room that's
what I would do I would do something
like that and I would just make sure you
know also if you really don't have time
to work out but it really helped you
during the day is to bring an apple and
to pack a healthy lunch hostess saves
you money also gives you more of a lunch
hour because you're not driving to and
from wherever the [ __ ] you're going you
go right down to the cafeteria you knock
it out you chill the [ __ ] out you know
you have something healthy in your
afternoon break and that's the biggest
thing do if you're not putting mistakes
into your [ __ ] mouth you're going to
get more results from your workout and
you know your clothes are fitting better
and the same way you get addicted to
eating bad salt sugar salt sugar you can
get addicted to eating well which were
is
we're on that right now all right one
trick pony
I hate Billy balls my wife loved your
pie crust video oh by the way you know I
tried lied in my for my crust for the
first time and it was a total
GameChanger the best crust I ever made
it did feel weird to smell bacon as I
was making the pie crust but thank you
to everybody that suggested that whoo
you know your critique really helped my
pie crust thank you all right so anyways
he this person says she's a fan of yours
as well you know the pie crust video
she's a fan of you as well and has been
exposed to hours of your podcast she
likes you bill let me lead with that
well here comes the big [ __ ] slap in
the face but of course like all great
women she still has a capacity to chop a
man down at the knees after the video I
casually said can't wait for the next
one she responded in a no sweetie tone
with haha well how many of these tricks
do you think he has up his sleeve this
resulted in a long discussion where I
defended your potential skills and she
went with the I love Bill burr I'm just
assuming he doesn't have much more to
rival this pie crust whether you can
make a full series out of these videos
or not can you please explain to my wife
that you're not a one-trick pony if you
are a one-trick pony
it's [ __ ] not fair to assume this
much thanks come back to Wisconsin home
of corruption as seen in documentaries
well you know something as you get older
as a man you understand where that's
coming from
why your wife as you said like all great
women always have to take you out of the
knees what it is as much as you got to
stop internalizing that and taking it
personally what it is is that it's
almost like a subconscious fear thing
that they have you don't mean like when
they don't know you and they see you
doing something they have a positive
reaction to a gun oh look you can make a
pie crust
I bet he's going to be a great dad right
they think [ __ ] like that but after they
get with you and then they love you and
they don't want to lose you when they
see you continuing to grow as a person
they with it I can't even say this is a
female thing this is like a thing in
general that people do in relationships
is you actually hold back the person you
love because you see them expanding on
who they are because it's something new
and different and moves in a different
direction I think subconsciously a
certain type of person feels insecure so
then they have to tether it to the
ground with [ __ ] criticism rather
than encouraging the person so I think
that that's where it's coming from but
as far as addressing it like I will just
say that as far as my cooking and baking
like you don't just know how to make
cornflake and you can also make a pie
crust you know what I mean knowing how
to make a pie crust take all of your
[ __ ] to the next level okay
like know like know this because I can
do that like back in the day I used to
look at like making like a quiche or
something like that going oh my god
that's [ __ ] impossible the crust
alone or making a turkey potpie or
anything that involves having a crust
you can add that I recently have learned
how to smoke meat you know I smoked ribs
I can make all of my my my mother before
we when we all moved out she wrote out
all of her recipes hand wrote them all
out on cards and we have all of them and
we can all cook the meals that she made
when we were growing up like I can make
you Hungarian Goulash and you know what
else I can make the [ __ ] noodles from
scratch I took a pasta making class you
know as you suspected sir your wife has
no idea what the [ __ ] she's talking
about what it really was it was coming
from a place of insecurity and jealousy
and right now she's going to roll her
eyes and like oh my god but bla bla bla
it's [ __ ] true you know because
that's really just like a just like to
have like that that Oh sweetie tone you
know they do that [ __ ]
you know you go up you start looking a
little too good you get a new new suit
right you're looking a little they got a
[ __ ] they got a got to make a comment
they [ __ ] do it with each other with
hilarious I think that's one of the main
reasons that's [ __ ] them up by the way
you know and they always talk about the
wage gap and all that one of the biggest
problems with the wage gap is not men
it's the fact that women don't get
together and create businesses enough
they just don't do it because they're
too busy gonna look at this [ __ ] and
[ __ ] look at her she's too [ __ ]
skinny she needs to eat something she's
got on too much [ __ ] out she knows what
she's doing
you know they don't work well together I
don't know why but that's not our fault
I'm sure it is though if you watch the
view I'm sure they could spin it around
to us so yes sir I actually absolutely
love cooking and it isn't the only trick
I have up my sleeve
I could obviously make more of those but
the thing about it was was that was the
specific skill it was for the holidays
and people have suggested well why don't
you do one on how to smoke me - why
don't you we'll do one about making
pasta from scratch my thing is because
you could watch Mario Batali do it you
can watch champion smokers do it so I
guess what makes mine different is that
I make it funny you know I just looked
at it one [ __ ] random thing that I
was going to do but you know now that
she's been a douche about it you know I
don't make another one at some point I
guess well let's see what the [ __ ] will
I do the turkey pot pie on the Big Green
Egg I mean I've watched youtube videos
of all of those I just didn't really saw
somebody do like is there a pie crust
video and I just thought it'd be fun I
literally feel like I'm in a
relationship right now like I'm sorry
that that video annoyed you oh god it's
so [ __ ] Moody yeah I will figure out
something else
to make one of those I'll do like one a
year nice actually give me some ideas
like maybe I'll do one other summer's
coming all right
going to show up the fourth of July is a
quick [ __ ] pink in May you know maybe
I'll do it maybe I'll do it I just don't
like committing this [ __ ] like that I
love not having a job which is why I'm a
[ __ ] comedian I really enjoyed this
whole I work when I want to rather than
a daily need 20 episodes of this alright
Thursday afternoon podcast got me laid
bill oh something positive Oh John do
you really think you could get somebody
else laid [ __ ] disease it's probably
why we died eight years earlier just
because they just won't give it up but
if you get yourself out in front of it
next time your wife does that to you sir
next time she takes you out at the knees
just come up to her and Stroke the side
of her face
you know when we go out and get a new
car and you know honey don't you think
you're a little bit old for that car you
know does one of those things makes you
feel stupid right just walk up you
stroke the side of the face just all
sweetie don't worry I'm not going to
leave you okay it's okay Shh it's okay
I know I look good in the car I'm sorry
something like that something creepy all
right bill last week on New Year's Eve
my wife and I listened to your podcast
after we put the kids to bed we drank
wine and laughed our asses off that's
great this woke us up energized us just
as the throwback clip came on it
appeared that we may have sex to ring in
the New Year well boy oh boy not more
than a few notes into the outro song we
were going at it it was all over just
moments after the song ended so maybe
four minutes or so a ball dropping bliss
my dick thanks you for the laughs and
the soundtrack did you guys [ __ ] to the
me under strong I don't think I needed
to know that all right all here it is
there it is this is the one I wanted to
read this is amazing overpopulation myth
bill how you're doing and I'm just
checking in on you to inform you that if
you go online and see for yourself how
much arable ara ble farmland and
resources there actually is in the world
you'll see that there is enough to feed
and home at least 100 billion people for
a provable fact I don't know that
sentence didn't make sense
did you like Voice Texas or did you
actually this is how you actually type
out sentences person goes so anytime you
hear anyone say that seven billion
people is too many people there th e IR
either seriously misinformed and or too
lazy to do some research or flat-out
lying from their teeth like our
so-called leaders and scientists must be
oh yeah they got to be lying because you
not you can't even spell their right
because within one to do two days of
research you can find studies that prove
what I say it's going to take me one to
two days to find it on the Internet this
is [ __ ] hilarious one day twenty two
days to research you can find studies
that prove what I say is true
parenthesis at least 100 billion now I
know you're in the business of waking
the masses up just like the late great
Bill Hicks no I'm not but do you realize
how serious the situation is regarding
the distraction and brainwashing is
organized by big business and they're
controlling family owners so as great as
I think you and your comedy are
mentioning overpopulation which is a
complete myth is doing them parentheses
big corporations and the country on them
a big service and adding to the
brainwashing anyway bill I know you're a
great man because of the subjects you
talk about during your shows but please
look for yourself and how much admirable
arable farmland there is and consider
the fact that all food grows completely
for free Wow all right well I'll tell
you this buddy I know I'm a [ __ ] so I
just looked up I looked at how many
people can the earth to stay
and it says Huntington's in the earth
support so 10 billion people is the
utmost population limit where food is
concerned that's the first one the next
one says more than 7 billion people
currently on the planet compared to 3
billion in 1967 that one doesn't say oh
I'll just long it's a video I want to
watch that current population is three
times the sustainable level that's the
next article how many people can the
earth sustain I'll click on this one I'm
trying to find anything that says
anything even remotely close to 100
million 100 billion here's a staggering
stat according to the United Nations the
world's current population of 7.2
billion it melts at 7.8 is projected to
increase by 1 billion over the next 12
years which would bring us to nine point
six billion by 2050 how can we sustain
all these people on the planet or rather
how many people can this planet
sustained that is the question Allen
wife's been explored in his latest book
countdown our last best hope for a
future on earth question mark Jesus
Christ a bunch of conversations bunch of
words top on a number where is the
[ __ ] number alright he has the chart
it wow this is kind of the next 50 years
we will need to produce as much food is
it ever been consumed for an entire
human history well that makes sense
because they'll be the most people
they'll be the most farts ever in the
history of human beings no there's no
[ __ ] number there so all I can tell
you is if you see the environmental
damage that seven point eight billion
people did if you're going to have a
hundred billion people like I mean at
this point in Africa there's barely any
landfill for wild animals it's all gets
all like for the most part down in the
southern part of the country it's all
like roped off it's finite you don't I
mean that completely surrounded
I'd have to say that I disagree and not
just by your spelling because I couldn't
read half the [ __ ] words you said
even when you spelled them right but
yeah no there's no [ __ ] way a hundred
billion people and there's any sort of
animal life left that isn't stuck in a
cage you know what I mean and also in
this last year I traveled to Singapore
Hong Kong in Mumbai India and I saw what
that next level of population looked
like - and I was breathing that air that
Singapore Singapore was was different
but Hong Kong and Mumbai India you could
almost taste the [ __ ] air and it was
just it was just way too many [ __ ]
people I can tell you that there's no
way out a billion people and I don't
understand why I need to look it up for
one to two days why couldn't you just
send me a link I would love for you to
be right but I'm going to go out on a
limb and say you're not I'm going to go
with the scientists on this one and also
this also sounds like you know when
people denied global warming not to get
all political but one political party
adamantly denied it for years and years
and years and now there's decades and
now they finally just go yeah we are
causing climate change but you know what
it's too late now so I imagine that
that's what we're going to do out here
we have a [ __ ] methane gas leak
that's been going on and I guess that's
brought it like ten times worse than
carbon dioxide as far as getting put
into the [ __ ] atmosphere as far as
heating it up and all that we're
completely [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
we're absolutely [ __ ] and selfishly I
hope I the end of my own life which is
the exact sort of thought process that
got us into this mess to begin with but
sir you're correct in assuming that I'm
a [ __ ] dope and I don't know what I'm
talking about but uh I'm just kind of
going with having travelled extensively
you know for the last 20 years on the
road and watching the population
increased Jeff in this country it's a
weird thing with the population that
keeps
like it sort of leveled off and I don't
know because there's no factories
anymore all I know is like I've usually
back in the day if I jumped on the
highway at 2:00 in the afternoon I was
good and now everywhere I go there's
like traffic I'm just look at these
people they're like you guys all stand
up comics does everybody work the third
shift how to [ __ ] are all these people
out on the road I don't know what's
going on do a lot of people work from
home and they're all driving out to get
a sandwich at that time I don't know you
know what let me look up
I heard the US population kind of
leveled off which is excited me that's
exciting to me you know US population
oh Jesus Christ oh can you [ __ ]
population by year let's do this alright
let's see what we got here
US population by year right let's go
back to 1997 there was two point seven
265 million and now there's three
hundred twenty two point zero seven
million so it's gone up by like 50
million is that enough to notice well
that's actually you know that's
significant right that's like an Inc 20
percent increase I think I'm making some
point all right let's move on here all
right I advise changing high school
Gabriel I'm a freshman in high school
and would like to know your perspective
on my situation I currently attended a
performing arts high school and majored
in Jazz Studies that's one cool I
enjoyed and all but the first semester
has passed I found out that jazz is
something I don't want to do in life
rather than carry on for the next three
years of this major I'd rather change
school to major something that would
benefit me in the long run especially if
I want to attend big schools like
Harvard well that's good man you tried
something you've realized early on you
don't like it and you got enough
strength to be like communicating I
don't want to do this and you'll need
something else it's all good so far the
problem is that leaving my current
school I could possibly devastate the
fans I'm in well Jesus became an ego out
of nowhere and also hurt some friends my
director has placed me in some good band
and I even get paid money for playing
gay I'll see you crushing it I would
feel child to leave my director as he
has put me in a position that many
others would gladly take this question
has been tearing me apart for a while
what do you think bill should I say or
should I go also if I do decide to leave
do you think I should tell my friends
and directors than I that I am or should
I just go out quietly they would you
have to do in life what makes you happy
if you try to make other people happy
that's all you're going to do and you're
not going to be happy and then you're
going to be miserable to be around you
can turn into a bitter person who didn't
do what they wanted to do in life and no
one wants to be around that guy alright
so as much as it's going to hurt them
you got to leave and you got to tell
them and you have to tell them why
you're going to leave and just say
listen I'm just not happy doing this I
understand that I'm lucky and that a lot
of people would kill to be in my
position so I feel that someone should
at least be happy and be excited you
know if people desire to be in my
position and I'm occupying that position
and I'm not happy I'm doing an injustice
to myself and one of you guys alright I
apologize I'm sorry and then that's it
and you know it's a great life lessons
sometimes you know when you ask for what
you want people get hurt and you know I
don't mean you physically have to hurt
him you know the bottom lip Quivers a
little bit that's all I'm saying that's
it but don't go out quietly don't sneak
out the back door be a man or will man
about it and [ __ ] you know be an
adult alright that's it then you should
be commended for understanding that you
don't like something and and not just
staying in it
alright book recommendations alright hey
Bill
not to start off by blowing smoke up
your ass but after f is for family is a
phenomenal show as me cracking up
non-stop but I digress well thank you I
appreciate that gives me a chance to
promote the show if you haven't watched
yet please check out after the family
evidently we're doing great on the old
Netflix
a the person says I remember you
mentioned you read open oh that you read
open by Andre Agassi so I picked it up
and started reading it it truly is one
of the books that's tough to put down
was wondering if you had any other
recommendations that you've read of late
Thanks and go [ __ ] yourself that
comedian book that I mentioned I have it
downstairs it's like the history of
stand-up comedy let me look it up here
which would take me forever to get
through because every time they bring up
a name like who the [ __ ] is that guy and
then I look them up and then I'm on the
internet but it's been them it's been a
joy history of stand-up comedy book
there it is all right this is what I've
been reading it's called the comedian's
drunks the scoundrels in the history of
American comedy Jesus Christ how about
brilliant do you know any geniuses in
there no not no nod to prior Lenny Bruce
none of that all right yeah so I would
tell that's what I've been reading and I
don't know I'm in another one of those
modes when I'm just playing a lot of
drums and I'm cooking in that type of
stuff and also feeling the pressure to
put out another cooking video - shut up
somebody that I've never met before how
[ __ ] ridiculous is that I should just
let it go you know I should but you know
what I'm not gonna you know what maybe
I'll make a [ __ ] it I'll make a
breakfast one I made a pie one I'll make
a breakfast one I'll make a lunch one
I'll make a data or a supper one I'll do
it over throughout the [ __ ] use all
right that'll Beall basic cooking by a
basic [ __ ] all right that's the podcast
for this week go [ __ ] yourselves I'll
check in on you on Thursday the
brand-new year I have like two stand-up
gigs books because I'm trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] is going to go on with
this show if we're going to get a second
season I need to know but I think I'm
just going to start booking [ __ ] because
that's how this business works
you know if you
you booked a bunch of [ __ ] then they
just go oh let's [ __ ] give you
something right in the middle of all
that other [ __ ] that you book if you
don't book anything then you're just
going to be staring at your phone and
it's never going to ring what are you
[ __ ] which billion the soo-eun it's
superstitious stuff well maybe I am I
have no idea but uh Paul virzi is going
to try to not drink starting today until
the beginning of April and I told them
that I would sort of half-ass committed
that I would do it with them so I'm sort
of on the wagon right now I didn't drink
last night I don't really have any
desire to do it today I'm [ __ ] wiped
out so we'll see I'm going to try to see
I'll try to go as long as I can alright
that's it go [ __ ] yourself so I'll talk
to you on Thursday